I got to admit I'm both excited and a
little nervous I'm in the hot seat I'm
Jenny Luna and I'm a podcast producer at
Stanford Graduate School of
Business welcome to think fast talk
smart the podcast today we have a bit of
a Twist on our normal episode format I'm
going to sit in the host seat and put
Matt in the hot seat Matt's new book
think faster talk smarter how to speak
successfully when you're put on the spot
launches at the end of this month so I
thought it would be fun to put him in
the hot seat and ask him his thoughts on
spontaneous speaking Welcome Matt are
you ready for this I am super excited
for this Jenny thank you I'm going to do
my best to think faster and talk smarter
okay let's get started your new book is
on spontaneous speaking how do you
define that and what made you want to
focus on that for your book throughout
my life I have always been spontaneous
speaking with the last name Abrahams AB
I have always gone first so in
elementary school in high school even in
college and graduate school I was always
the first person asked to speak I know
what it feels like to be put on the spot
and that's really what spontaneous
speaking is all about it's about that
moment where you are called on to step
up and say something maybe it's
answering a question giving feedback in
the moment fixing a mistake you made
being called on to introduce somebody or
even during small talk so spontaneous if
you think about it happens all the time
in our personal lives and our
professional lives I didn't realize this
had such personal roots for you Matt I
really like that and and so how did you
come to be interested in kind of helping
others with this concept about a decade
ago the Deans at the business school
came to me with a problem and the
problem was that our incredibly bright
students were panicking and choking in
cold call situations you know where the
professor says what do you think and you
have to respond our stud students who
knew the answers who were very bright
could not in the moment respond and they
asked me can you help and as a result of
that I got very interested in exploring
how we can be better speakers in the
moment and through doing research on my
own looking into other fields and
collaborating with people here at the
business school but especially with my
colleague from the arts department Adam
Tobin who's an excellent improviser came
up with a lot of this
content interesting okay and I know
you're famous around campus and out in
the world for this six-step methodology
on spontaneous speaking can you walk us
through those steps famous is a big word
uh but uh I I've definitely spent a lot
of time talking about this the
methodology that I've come up with and
that we walk all of our MBA students
through they can opt in to learn this
content and most of them do it's really
divided into two major areas mindset and
messaging so we have to adjust our
mindset and part of mindset is also
dealing with anxiety and listening and
then messaging is about how we structure
our messages and then how do we focus
them on this podcast we've talked a lot
about structure we've talked a lot about
being concise and clear and those are
all part of the six-step methodology
yeah we've talked a lot about managing
anxiety a few times on this podcast
we've had a lot of guests talk about it
um you did a whole episode on it a few
years ago it's one of our more popular
episodes among listeners uh so let's
let's drill down more into the mindset
part of your methodology can you help us
understand these different shifts that
you suggest in a mindset and also tell
us what you mean when you write in the
book about missed takes the way we
approach communication period but
especially spontaneous communication
really matters and there are a couple
key mindset shifts I think that we we
should adopt to feel more comfortable
and confident in spontaneous situations
first is we often strive for Perfection
and I would argue that we should rather
be looking for connection on the very
first day of the Strategic communication
class I co- te I have the audacity to
say to my
students maximize your mediocrity and
Jenny you should see their jaws drop
these students have never been told to
be mediocre but here's the logic behind
that when we strive to be great when we
strive to be right or perfect in our
communication it actually prevents us
from doing it well at all and it comes
down to a simple issue of cognitive
bandwidth think of your brain as a
computer it's not a Perfect Analogy but
when you're running your your laptop or
your phone and you have lots of apps or
windows open your computer is not
running as effectively as it could in in
essence everything's a little slower the
same thing is true when you're speaking
and you're monitoring everything you're
saying and judging and evaluating it as
you're saying it or even before you're
saying it you're not as effective so
when we dial the volume down we can
actually perform better so I'm not
saying we shouldn't judge and evaluate
what we say we should but if we turn the
volume down a little bit we can do it
better so the whole saying I tell my
students on that first day is maximize
mediocrity so you can achieve greatness
when we focus on connecting with our
audience delivering a message that's
relevant for them we can actually do it
better if we're not judging and
evaluating so that's the first mindset
shift connection over Perfection the
second is to see these spontaneous
speaking situations as opportunities
rather than threats many of us when
we're put under the gauntlet of Q&A or
asked for feedback in the moment we feel
like we have to defend our position we
have to be perfect in the threat of
Challenge and so how do we deal with
that we get in a very tight body posture
our responses are are Curt and short our
tone is Harsh if we see these as
opportunities as the ability to connect
to expand to collaborate it changes is
completely how we feel now I'm not naive
I know people do actually challenge us
but even in those moments if we see it
as an opportunity to connect it really
changes things so we want to strive for
connection over Perfection we want to
see these circumstances as opportunities
and then finally many of us fear making
mistakes we don't want to make mistakes
and as we've talked about on this
podcast before mistakes are ways that we
learn you you have to break a few things
in order to actually learn and progress
so I i' like to encourage people to
reframe how they see mistakes and and
you know in the making of films or
television they they do lots of takes
we've all seen that little clapboard
that comes down they say take one take
two I think if we see our communication
and the and the things that go wrong as
M takes rather than mistakes it can
really help us so when a movie director
is looking at a particular scene she
might be asking the actors to do it
again and again different takes not
because anyone take is wrong but because
they're looking for something a little
different maybe you do it standing up
versus sitting maybe you put a little
more emotion in one part versus the
other so when things don't go the way we
want them to if we see them as a missed
take just another opportunity to do it
differently next time that feels very
different than having gotten it wrong so
those three mindset shifts can make a
big difference in our communication I
love this concept of turning the volume
down turning the internal volume down
and then taking things not threats but
as opportunities and then reframing into
a m take instead of a mistake that's
great when it comes to structure I love
in your book how you provide series of
examples and advice for situations we
find ourselves in like small talk making
an apology giving a toast or an
introduction and giving feedback that's
a big one um the one structure that I
put into use right away was your
pitching structure can you share that
with listeners and then give an example
of pitching structure sure so often
we're in these circumstances where we
have to sell an idea or sell a product
or a service and we're put on the spot
you you literally get in the elevator
with somebody and they say what do you
do and you have to give that elevator
pitch and it can be hard as a result of
work I've done here at the business
school with lots of entrepreneurs I
developed a four sentence structured
pitch if you finish these sentence
starters you have a good pitch and they
are what if you could
so that for example and that's not all
so if you finish each one of those it
gives you a really tight clear pitch and
idea of what it is that you are selling
if you will so let's say I was
explaining to somebody about our podcast
think fast talk smart something that you
do amazing work for and somebody let's
say I'm in an elevator I'm at a small
talk uh chitchat situation somebody says
tell me about your podcast I would say
what if you could learn to hone and
develop your communication skills so
that you can achieve your personal and
professional goals for example you could
learn how to be more confident more
persuasive and even more creative in
your communication and that's not all
you'll join a wonderful community of
other people who are also trying to
build their communication skills do you
hear how just finishing those four
sentences really provides a tight clear
pitch it makes it relevant it makes it
impactful and memorable I'm sold this
sounds like a fantastic podcast well you
should listen to it
maybe uh something that we hear time and
again from our guests and from our
listeners is how well you do with
paraphrasing being concise and being
clear you have a chapter in your new
book what you call the F-word of
spontaneous speaking so can you give us
some advice around that F-word for Focus
not that naughty word that some of you
were were talking about I think
paraphrasing is a critical tool in
communication and one of the ways that
you can be more focused is to make sure
that what you're saying is relevant and
targeted to your audience asking
clarifying questions and paraphrasing
serves as a tool to help you focus so if
we are in a conversation and you ask me
for feedback I could jump right into
giving feedback or I might say I might
ask you a question do you want feedback
about what you said about what we could
do differently in the future and that
clarifying question helps me Focus so
there's a lot we can do to help focus
our messages based on what we do before
we actually provide those messages
certainly there are things we can do
once we're speaking as well I'm a huge
fan of trying to eliminate extraneous
words or acronyms or jargon so really
focusing on focusing our messages is
critical especially in spontaneous
speaking because so often we are
actually taking people along the Journey
of ourselves discovering what we want to
say as we say it and we say much more
than we need to and Jenny you've heard
me say this many times but I'll share it
again my mother has this wonderful
saying that gets to the heart of this
tell me the time don't build me the
clock focus is a great segue into my
next question we've had a lot of guests
talk about mindfulness taking a pause
focusing on the breath when we're
getting anxious about our communication
and I know that you practice Marshall
arts and you have for many years right I
have decades yes so what similarities
I'm curious do you see between
communication and martial arts I love
this question and thank you for asking I
don't often share about my martial arts
Journey but I I've been doing the
martial arts for four decades now I've
I've studied many many styles I still uh
participate and teach the martial arts
today and it it's been so instructive to
me in so many ways but in terms of
communication the martial arts teach you
to be present to respond to what's
happening in front of you to think about
how how your moves or what it is that
you do impacts not just the person in
front of you but the environment and
situation and all of those are mirrored
in communication I am a better
Communicator because of my martial arts
and perhaps a better martial artist
because of my communication but they're
they're intimately linked I encourage
everybody to try to find a physical
practice that can inform our day-to-day
interactions and who we are in the world
and for me the martial arts of done that
I know you tell a great story about a
martial arts experience you had as a
young person I'm wondering if you can
tell that story again just while we have
more listeners right
now thank you Jenny the perhaps the most
embarrassing moment of my entire life
happened when I was a 14-year-old boy on
the very first day of my freshman year
my English Professor had all of us stand
up and tell what we did that summer of
course I went first as I said uh being
first row first seat and at the end of
the day he came up to me and said Matt
you're good at this talking thing I need
you to go to this speech tournament this
Friday I think every teacher had to send
one student from their classes so I was
his student and he said give a speech on
something that's important to you so
begrudgingly I went I put on you know I
had my dad tie a tie for me I was
wearing pants that were way too short I
had grown over the summer I show up 7:30
in the morning giving a speech on the
martial arts that was important to me
then as it is now and in the room are 40
or 50 people the parents of my friends
who are judging my friends the girl I
liked is in the room it's my turn to go
I'm so nervous I am so nervous so
nervous that I forgot to put on my
special Karate pants if you know
anything about the martial arts the
pants you wear are very loose fitting so
you can do kicks and that's exactly how
I started my speech with a karate kick
it got everybody's attention and it
really got their attention because when
I did this kick I ripped my pants I kid
you not from zipper to Belt Buckle in
the first 10 seconds of a 10-minute
speech and it is at that moment and from
that moment that I became fascinated by
the impact of anxiety on communication
and that's what really motivated me to
actually study it and do everything that
I've done all goes back to that gym on a
Saturday morning as a 14-year-old boy so
yes the martial arts had a huge impact
on me it exposed me to so many things
literally and figuratively that's a
great story and there are so many things
that influence our work that come from
our personal lives as an example of that
Matt let's take a break from spontaneous
speaking and ask you about hosting this
podcast I feel very fortunate to be part
of our small But Mighty team and I'm
curious how you feel about having
completed a 100 episodes the first word
that comes to mind is gratitude it has
been a true pleasure to work with you
Jenny in all the the work you do behind
the scenes to make this thing a success
uh our colleague Neil and others in in
the marketing communication team is is
fantastic but the thing that I'm most
grateful for is just the connection that
I and we have with our listeners it has
been truly a blessing and just amazing
to get to know people from all over the
world from all walks of life from places
I've never heard of who are not just
benefiting from the podcast but also
connecting to our larger community and
really helping each other and role
modeling some of the things that we talk
about I have learned more hosting this
podcast from our guests and our audience
members than I ever thought possible so
when you ask me what do I think about it
and how do I reflect on this it's it's
really just from a place of gratitude
it's been awesome okay well I thought
we'd end Today's show a little bit
differently since on a prior episode
you've answered the questions that you
ask all of the guests I want to put you
to the test and ask you to think faster
and talk smarter I'm going to give you
three prompts that reflect some of the
situations that you provide in your new
book and ask you to respond are you
ready for that I am and just so
everybody knows I have no idea what
Jenny is going to ask me okay well I
treasure feedback what is one thing you
would suggest that I could do to be a
better podcast host I'm going to
Leverage The what so what now what
structure that I teach and for those of
you who haven't heard me talk about this
what is the information the idea the
product the service in this case the
feedback the so what is why is it
important and the now what is what could
the person do differently or or what
comes next so I'm going to find some
constructive thing to say because you
asked for it and I know you truly accept
feedback as a gift there are times where
you have been looking away in our
conversation and it for me it's a little
hard because I know you make such
intense eye contact always so the
feedback I would give you in the what is
sometimes you look away when you're
asking questions when you do that it
makes me feel disconnected that's the so
what so in the future I would ask that
you keep your eye contact on me or
whoever you're interviewing to really
help Foster that connection and make it
easier on the guest so it sounds like by
making more eye contact we can be more
successful in our communication and I'm
going to work on that wow great
paraphrase it takes a lot of listening
to be able to do that okay so we have a
new resource we're providing listeners
who want to learn English by listening
to our podcast how would you pitch that
to them
all right so we're going to try this
what if you could learn to feel more
comfortable speaking in the English
language so that you can participate in
some of your daily and business
interactions more comfortably for
example you could learn specific idioms
and phrasing that might help you in
situations that you encounter and that's
not all you'll be able to enjoy think
fast talk smart episodes even
more wonderful that structure really
does work well okay question three the
entire Stanford GSB Community has come
together to celebrate the podcast you
have to give a toast go oh boy so I have
a structure I teach in the book it's
called what wh ha a t for giving toasts
and tributes the W is why are we all
here the H is how are you the person
speaking connected then an anecdote or
two that's the A and then finally the
thanking or the toasting at the end so
it's whh a so I might say thank you all
for being here to celebrate the gsb's
think fast talk smart 100th anniversary
episode I Matt am the host of this
podcast and just one of of a small But
Mighty team of people that bring this to
you I remember back years ago when we
were first thinking of this idea and
brainstorming and wondering would
anybody ever listen let alone want to be
a guest on the podcast and it has been
fantastic to see that people actually do
want to listen and do want to join us so
I thank every single one of you for
being here and I thank every single one
of you for being a part of the think
fast talk smart family wonderful here
here and congratulations Matt not only
to 100 episodes but to your new book I
know we're all looking forward to
cracking that open um your passion for
communication and thank you for your
concise clear and helpful guidance as
always and I wish you well on the new
book that was a great convers and I look
forward to many more Jenny thank you so
much for all you do for the podcast for
sitting in and interviewing me while
this guest seat is pretty comfy I look
forward to getting back into the host
seat
[Music]
soon thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Michael Riley and me Matt
Abrahams for more information and
episodes visit gb. stanford.edu or
subscribe to our show wherever you get
your podcasts finally find us on social
media at Stanford
[Music]
GSB